THAT THAT
UPDATES A STORY. WE SPENT A
LOT OF TIME ON THIS MORNING
ON PFT LIVE THE NFL'S MEMO
FROM LAST NIGHT MAKING IT
CLEAR TO ALL THE TEAMS. NOT
THAT THE NFL NEEDED TO THAT
PLAYERS WHO WORK OUT AWAY
FROM THE FACILITY, EVEN IF
THEY'RE WORKING OUT TO STAY
IN FOOTBALL SHAPE. IF THEY
GET INJURED AND IT'S SERIOUS,
THE TEAM DOESN'T HAVE TO PAY
THEM
THAT IN MY ESTIMATION WAS A
MIDDLE FINGER TO THE UNION
BECAUSE THE UNION'S BEEN
AGITATING FOR PLAYERS TO NOT
WORK OUT AT THE TEAM FACILITY
AND IT WAS A MESSAGE TO THE
PLAYERS. HEY, YOU BETTER WORK
OUT AT THE TEAM FACILITY AND
IF YOU DO, YOU'RE COVERED.
YOUR SURGERY GETS PAID FOR
YOU. GET YOUR SALARY. YOU
OTHER BENEFITS AVAILABLE TO
YOU. SO, TOM PELLICER OF NFL
MEDIA AND IT'S INTERESTING
THAT THEY WOULD LEAK THIS TO
A GUY WHO WORKS FOR THE
LEAGUE, BUT TOM PELLICER OF
NFL, MEDIA HAS A MEMO THAT
WAS SENT TO THE PLAYERS.
IT'S YESTERDAY. AND FROM THE
PHONE CALL, THERE WERE SOME
HIGHLIGHTS AND THE ONE THAT
REALLY STANDS OUT TO ME IS
THAT AND AND I'M GOING TO
READ THIS DIRECTLY FROM THE
EMAIL. WE DISCUSSED THE NFL'S,
MEMO RELATING TO THE INJURY
SUFFERED BY ONE OF OUR
BROTHERS. THIS WEEK, THE NFL
HAS NEVER EVER SENT SUCH A
MEMO ABOUT VOLUNTARY WORKOUTS
WHICH IS CONFIRMATION THAT
YOUR POSITION IS BOTH RIGHT
TO USE A PLAYER'S SERIOUS ESS
INJURY AS A SCARE TACTIC TO
GET YOU TO COME RUNNING BACK
TO THESE WORK.
SCOUTS THIS MEMO IS YET
ANOTHER SIGN OF WHAT THEY
THINK OF YOU AND ALSO AFFIRM
THAT THEY SIMPLY WANT TO
CONTROL YOU YEAR, ROUND IN
ANY. AND EVERY WAY THAT THEY
CAN THAT IS A LOT OF HUFF AND
PUFF. THEY AIN'T GONNA BLOW
ANYBODY'S HOUSE DOWN WITH IT
THOUGH. BECAUSE HERE'S THE
BOTTOM LINE, CHAUHAN JAMES,
HE WOULD HAVE SUFFERED A TORN,
ACHILLES TENDON AT THE TEAM
FACILITY, WE WOULDN'T BE
HAVING THIS CONVERSATION.
HE'D GET HIS TEN MILLION
DOLLARS HE'D BE ELIGIBLE FOR.
ARE ALL OF THE OTHER BENEFITS
THEY BECOME AVAILABLE. NOW,
THEY SAY IN THIS MEMO, WE'VE
BEEN IN TOUCH WITH YOU ON
JAMES, DESPITE THE ONGOING
THREAT, THE OPEN THREAT OF AN
NFI. DESIGNATION JOANNE WAS
WORKING OUT TO STAY IN SHAPE
UNDER A PROGRAM, RECOMMENDED
TO HIM BY HIS COACH. I DON'T
CARE ABOUT THAT. YOU'RE NOT
WORKING OUT OF THE TEAM
FACILITY. YOU GOT TO BE
FACILITY. YOU KNOW WHAT?
WORKING OUT OF THE TEAM
THEY'RE GOING TO ARGUE THAT,
FACILITY. YOU KNOW WHAT?
BECAUSE HE WAS DOING WHAT THE
THEY'RE GOING TO ARGUE THAT,
COACH SAID, YOU SHOULD DO AT
BECAUSE HE WAS DOING WHAT THE
HOME, THAT THAT SOMEHOW THAT
COACH SAID, YOU SHOULD DO AT
SOMEHOW COUNTS AS BEING AT
HOME, THAT THAT SOMEHOW THAT
AN EXTENSION, THE TEAM
SOMEHOW COUNTS AS BEING AT
IF THAT'S THEIR POINT, THAT
AN EXTENSION, THE TEAM
SHOULD HAVE BEEN THE LEAD OF
IF THAT'S THEIR POINT, THAT
THE MEMO NOT BURIED NEAR THE
SHOULD HAVE BEEN THE LEAD OF
BOTTOM OF IT. I I DON'T THINK
THE MEMO NOT BURIED NEAR THE
THERE'S AN ARGUMENT TO BE
BOTTOM OF IT. I I DON'T THINK
MADE THAT JUWAN. JAMES IS NOT
THERE'S AN ARGUMENT TO BE
GOING TO BE AT RISK OF LOSING
MADE THAT JUWAN. JAMES IS NOT
AT SERIOUS RISK OF LOSING
GOING TO BE AT RISK OF LOSING
THAT MONEY. SO, LOOK, THEY
AT SERIOUS RISK OF LOSING
GOT TO DO WHAT THEY GOT TO DO.
THAT MONEY. SO, LOOK, THEY
I GET IT. THEY STAKED OUT A
GOT TO DO WHAT THEY GOT TO DO.
DIFFICULT POSITION THAT NEVER
I GET IT. THEY STAKED OUT A
MADE MUCH SENSE TO ME. AND
DIFFICULT POSITION THAT NEVER
AND NOW THAT THEY CAN, THE
MADE MUCH SENSE TO ME. AND
ONLY REACTION IS, YOU KNOW,
AND NOW THAT THEY CAN, THE
THEY SAY IN THE LAW, WHEN THE
ONLY REACTION IS, YOU KNOW,
LAW, WHEN THE LAW IS ON YOUR
THEY SAY IN THE LAW, WHEN THE
SIDE, POUND ON THE LAW. WHEN
LAW, WHEN THE LAW IS ON YOUR
THE FACTS ON YOUR SIDE POUND
SIDE, POUND ON THE LAW. WHEN
ON THE FACTS, WHEN NEITHER'S
THE FACTS ON YOUR SIDE POUND
ON YOUR SIDE POUND ON THE
ON THE FACTS, WHEN NEITHER'S
WHEN NEITHER'S ON YOUR SIDE,
ON YOUR SIDE POUND ON THE
POUND ON THE TABLE. THIS IS
WHEN NEITHER'S ON YOUR SIDE,
JUST SOME
POUND ON THE TABLE. THIS IS
ON THE TABLE BY THE UNION
JUST SOME
BECAUSE I DON'T THINK IT'S
ON THE TABLE BY THE UNION
ANYTHING ELSE THEY CAN REALLY
BECAUSE I DON'T THINK IT'S
SAY, ALL RIGHT? AND I THINK
ANYTHING ELSE THEY CAN REALLY
YOU WROTE THIS MIC THAT
SAY, ALL RIGHT? AND I THINK
THERE'S PRECEDENT FOR WHAT
YOU WROTE THIS MIC THAT
ALL THE WAY BACK TO 1977. SO
THERE'S PRECEDENT FOR WHAT
NOT LIKE, THIS IS SOMETHING
ALL THE WAY BACK TO 1977. SO
THAT IS BRAND-NEW FOR THE
NOT LIKE, THIS IS SOMETHING
PLAYERS FOR THE UNION FOR
THAT IS BRAND-NEW FOR THE
TEAMS FOR CONTRACTS IN ANY
PLAYERS FOR THE UNION FOR
SITUATION LIKE THAT. SO AND
TEAMS FOR CONTRACTS IN ANY
EVEN SO YOU KNOW, YOU WANT TO
SITUATION LIKE THAT. SO AND
TALK ABOUT WHAT WAS
EVEN SO YOU KNOW, YOU WANT TO
COLLECTIVELY BARGAINED AND
TALK ABOUT WHAT WAS
THAT'S THE OFFSEASON PROGRAM,
COLLECTIVELY BARGAINED AND
VOLUNTARY OFFSEASON PROGRAM.
THAT'S THE OFFSEASON PROGRAM,
GUYS DO.
VOLUNTARY OFFSEASON PROGRAM.
DO NOT HAVE TO GO TO. ALL
GUYS DO.
RIGHT, SO THAT IS JUST WHAT
DO NOT HAVE TO GO TO. ALL
THAT IS BUT I THINK IF YOU'RE
RIGHT, SO THAT IS JUST WHAT
TALKING ABOUT INJURY
THAT IS BUT I THINK IF YOU'RE
PROTECTIONS LIKE I SAID, IF
TALKING ABOUT INJURY
THIS IS NOT SOMETHING THAT'S
PROTECTIONS LIKE I SAID, IF
NEW. SO IT'S REALLY
THIS IS NOT SOMETHING THAT'S
INTERESTING TO ME JUST HOW
NEW. SO IT'S REALLY
THIS IS GOING TO PLAY OUT
INTERESTING TO ME JUST HOW
BETWEEN THE LEAGUE AND THE
THIS IS GOING TO PLAY OUT
UNION BECAUSE IT'S IT FEELS
BETWEEN THE LEAGUE AND THE
LIKE IT'S A BATTLE AT THE
UNION BECAUSE IT'S IT FEELS
UNION CAN'T REALLY WIN AND I
LIKE IT'S A BATTLE AT THE
ALWAYS TALK ABOUT THIS, LIKE,
UNION CAN'T REALLY WIN AND I
YOU KNOW, YOU GOT TO PICK
ALWAYS TALK ABOUT THIS, LIKE,
BATTLES THAT YOU CAN WIN, AND
YOU KNOW, YOU GOT TO PICK
LIKE FOR THE PA, IN THIS OOKS
BATTLES THAT YOU CAN WIN, AND
PARTICULAR CASE THAT I JUST
LIKE FOR THE PA, IN THIS OOKS
DON'T
PARTICULAR CASE THAT I JUST
THEY'RE GOING TO GET THEIR
DON'T
MIKE.
THEY'RE GOING TO GET THEIR
AND AND LOOK, I HAVE ALWAYS
MIKE.
SUPPORTED PLAYER CAUSES AND
AND AND LOOK, I HAVE ALWAYS
IT ALWAYS UPSETS ME. THAT
SUPPORTED PLAYER CAUSES AND
FANS WILL ALIGN WITH THE
IT ALWAYS UPSETS ME. THAT
BILLIONAIRE'S OVER THE
FANS WILL ALIGN WITH THE
PLAYERS. WHENEVER SOMETHING
BILLIONAIRE'S OVER THE
LIKE THIS GOES DOWN, WHEN
PLAYERS. WHENEVER SOMETHING
A POTENTIAL WORK. STOPPAGE,
LIKE THIS GOES DOWN, WHEN
WHEN THERE'S A FIGHT AND WE
A POTENTIAL WORK. STOPPAGE,
HAVE HIGHLIGHTED IN THE PAST
WHEN THERE'S A FIGHT AND WE
SITUATIONS WHERE THE UNION
HAVE HIGHLIGHTED IN THE PAST
HAS CAUGHT THE LEAGUE WITH
SITUATIONS WHERE THE UNION
HIS HAND, IN THE COOKIE JAR
HAS CAUGHT THE LEAGUE WITH
ON CERTAIN CALCULATIONS. AND
HIS HAND, IN THE COOKIE JAR
SUPPORTING THE PLAYERS AND
ON CERTAIN CALCULATIONS. AND
I'M EASY TO FIND IF THERE
SUPPORTING THE PLAYERS AND
REALLY IS AN ARGUMENT TO BE
I'M EASY TO FIND IF THERE
MADE THAT YOU ON JAMES,
REALLY IS AN ARGUMENT TO BE
GET HIS MONEY. TELL ME GET,
MADE THAT YOU ON JAMES,
ON RECORD COME ON THE SHOW.
GET HIS MONEY. TELL ME GET,
THEY DO I KNOW THOSE FOLKS
ON RECORD COME ON THE SHOW.
AND I JUST I THINK THIS WAS
THEY DO I KNOW THOSE FOLKS
ARE IN POSITIONS OF UNION, HO
AND I JUST I THINK THIS WAS
LEADERSHIP TO VENT THEIR
ARE IN POSITIONS OF UNION, HO
FRUSTRATIONS ABOUT WHAT
LEADERSHIP TO VENT THEIR
HAPPENED LAST YEAR. AND THE
FRUSTRATIONS ABOUT WHAT
WAS MADE THAT THIS WAS
HAPPENED LAST YEAR. AND THE
HARMLESS. IT'S NOT HARMLESS
WAS MADE THAT THIS WAS
WHEN A GUY BLOWS OUT AND
HARMLESS. IT'S NOT HARMLESS
ACHILLES TENDON AND HE'S
WHEN A GUY BLOWS OUT AND
GOING TO BE OUT TEN MILLION
ACHILLES TENDON AND HE'S
DOLLARS OR MORE FOR 2021 AND
GOING TO BE OUT TEN MILLION
MAY END UP NEVER PLAYING AGAIN
DOLLARS OR MORE FOR 2021 AND
IN THE NFL.
MAY END UP NEVER PLAYING AGAIN
BECAUSE THE BRONCOS ARE
IN THE NFL.
LIKELY GOING TO SAY WE VOID
BECAUSE THE BRONCOS ARE
YOUR GUARANTEES. SD EEWE Y MOU'